logo no início quando a gente percebe
que a criança é diferente tem algo que
não está da mesma forma a criança mudou
a criança tem o seu lamento tem um
comportamento diferenciado a gente
começa a interpretar tudo da forma como
a gente pensa que é
mas na verdade não é tão às vezes o
autismo ele vem como um filme que você
assistiu e você acha que o seu filho vai
ser daquela maneira vai se comportar
daquela forma às vezes vem como uma
idéia de um vizinho de uma criança que
estudou na mesma escola que você
estudava jamais você tem uma ideia
completa do que essa criança pode ser do
que ela será o que mais nos preocupa é
normalmente a pensar no futuro dessa
criança quando nós temos o diagnóstico
da nossa filha
eu percebi que ela tinha os
comportamentos muito esquisitos
essa é a verdade muito esquisitos de
balançar as mãos de andar na ponta dos
pés de colocar a boca em tudo de
landeira as coisas de olhar de uma forma
diferente lateral ou virando a cabeça
fechar os olhos e ska e claro que no
começo a gente não sabe interpretar do
que se trata porque ela está agindo
assim porque ela amanhece e vai dormir
com os deles nos ouvidos que ela tantas
ouvido o tempo inteiro
foram muitas perguntas que logo no
começo eu tive a graça de ser
apresentado à integração sensor
uma médica ela me falou ele a sua filha
tem muita disfunção sensorial
eu falei o que é isso aí já estava no
final da consulta eu falei não conta eu
vou pra casa eu vou descobrir o que isso
é
e eu descobri o que é e eu descobri que
realmente isso é uma verdade para o
autismo do mais funcional ao severo em
algum grau todos os autistas têm
disfunção no processamento sensorial
eu falei eu vou por esse caminho eu vou
pelo caminho da vamos fazer uma
varredura na parte biológica vamos
tratar essa partida tão importante
mas também eu quero abordar as questões
sensoriais porque isso está incomodando
muito a minha filha ea vida dela nua
sendo fácil não deve ser fácil acordar
com de duvido
não deve ser fácil não suportará estarem
ligados públicos
eu discordo dessa questão que o autista
negócio está isolado no mundo isolado eu
acho que ele só porque ele não suporta e
aí vem a tempo render tem problema em
falar assim crianças autistas reagem de
forma incomum ao mundo estranho que é
certo
o mundo a qual tentam desesperadamente
impor alguma ordem então é uma questão
de ordem é uma questão de entrada
desarmoniosa de informações
o cérebro ele comanda as funções do
nosso corpo acho que todos concordamos
a gente conhece a opção visão tato
paladar olfato o cérebro ele comanda as
respostas do nosso corpo aos estímulos
recebidos se a uma recepção de
informações desarmoniosa a nossa
resposta também será organizada e fora
do padrão normal
então enquanto eu estou
está sorrindo conversando com você e com
ela e com ele aprendendo meu celular
prestando atenção no parabéns pra uma
pessoa com autismo é um desafio um lugar
com muitos aromas cheiro de bolo cheiro
de perfume cheiro de borracha do balão
muito som crianças chorando crianças
sorrindo pessoas chegando portas abrindo
portas se fechando e todos nós somos
capazes de detectar as funções dos
nossos filhos é só você parar e pensar
um pouquinho eu gosto dessa falta porque
ela ilustra todos os pontos do corpo da
criança quase todos né
a dificuldade não ter mexido é fixação à
luz ou evitar a luz balançar o corpo que
pra gente pode ser uma coisa que a
lâmpada de balançar o corpo e na verdade
ele está se autorregulando se auto
modulando através daquele movimento
daquela busca não tolera algumas
texturas pode buscar ou evitar o toque
problemas com coordenação motora fina
problemas com coordenação motora grossa
e assim por diante
quando está muito aflorado muito forte a
gente observa que as crianças ficam mais
agitadas
normalmente a gente usa mais agitadas
mas esse mais agitado
normalmente incluir uma busca de subir
decorrer de balançar o corpo de agitar
as mãos
tudo isso é busca sensorial é preciso
cautela gente e observação compreensível
para não confundir uma reação que
disfunção do processamento sensorial com
a ação puramente comportamental eu já
mar
mesmo é porque a minha filha estava
muitos ouvidos eu tenho coragem de a um
calorzinho delas fala para o total
envolvido para o sampaio ouvido porque
pra mim era como se alguém dissesse sim
eu estou com dor de cabeça e eu queria
tomar o medicamento a pessoa não vai
tomar um medicamento mas eu preciso
tomar o medicamento minha cabeça tudo
indo eu preciso tapar o ouvido que o meu
ouvido dói
simples assim mas eu estou falando de
dor física mesmo
dói é preciso tratar porque dói é
preciso balancear porque o meu corpo
está mandando balançar preciso sacudir a
mão porque tem um formigamento na mão na
minha perna
já assistem estudos mapeando as regiões
cerebrais responsáveis pela disfunção do
processamento sensorial
isso é muito bom porque talvez
futuramente possa é esse a agir
diretamente naquele local que está
causando aquela disfunção eu passei a
ler biografias e autobiografias de
autistas e foi a melhor coisa que eu fiz
depois de ler sobre a parte sensorial
biológica eu mandei todos aqueles livros
e comecei a comprar livros dá tempo hand
é comecei a ler muito sobre a carga e
comecei a ler o que os outros têm para
nos dizer eu me sinto assim
eu bato a cabeça por isso eu saco nem
por isso eu fico balançando por isso
eles têm literalmente justificativas
para todos esses entre aspas
comportamentos o impacto da expansão
sensorial no aprendizado e no
comportamento eu nem preciso falar vocês
sabem na escola esse menino fica sentado
esse menino não fica quieto
às vezes é uma questão de acomodação
sensorial apenas néon o peso que
assistiu o filme dá tenha pensado que
ela criou uma máquina a máquina do brás
que nada mais é do que é um equipamento
de acomodação sensorial que ela foi
capaz de desenvolver né por a casa e
aquilo foi fantástico na vida dela teve
que levar aquela geringonça para a
universidade gente e todo mundo não pode
entrar que destruíram a máquina dela
jogaram pela janela mas ela fala gente
eu preciso disso para me equilibrar
nem eu conheci um menino de 13 anos
autista e ele falou assim às vezes é meu
vou ficar nervosa ela fala assim para
balançar porque ele está fazendo isso
para tem aquela fique calmo ele falou
mas eu estou fazendo isso michael mas
entendendo eu não tô nervoso então a avó
dele fica nervosa porque ele está
fazendo assim ela acha que ele está
nervoso que ele está fazendo assim ele
está fazendo isso para não ficar nervoso
ele estã se autorregulando através
daquele movimento é então eu acho que
esse tema acomodações sensoriais ele
deve ocupar a mente dos pais e dos
professores
extinguimos busca outros evitam todas as
crianças adolescentes adultos com a
crise como eu falei que no começo tem
algum grau de disfunção no processamento
sensorial uns mais outros menos um sabe
administrar de escrever outros não eles
apenas fazem né ou convivem com aquilo
ali porque enfim faz parte da estrutura
algumas crianças elas buscam a minha
filha na busca muito ela sempre se fala
só aqui nessa árvore é capaz de e até o
último galho da árvore
então ela sempre está subindo ela sempre
está correndo ela sempre está buscando
um desafio muro que é muito estreito mas
ela consegue até o final sem cárie uma
forma impressionante então ela está
sempre buscando se você for apertá lo
abraçá lá ela vai adorar outros eles não
gosto eles não querem que você toque a
tempo é uma que ela falou não gosta da
graça pra mim uma tortura né então a
gente precisa é colocar a gente na mente
das pessoas principalmente no âmbito
escolar que as crianças nesse com
autismo necessitam de avaliação de
perfil sensorial
você só pode começar uma intervenção
quando você conhece o perfil sensorial
daquela pessoa e sabe porquê que a
criança pode não estar aprendendo por
causa do perfume da professora aquele
perfume que ela usa superdoce ou
amadeirado enfim floral não importa pra
ele pode ser um incômodo tão grande que
está causando até ser devoto e isso a
gente tem relatado de autistas que
conseguem falar e dizer relatar
eu não suporto eu detesto eu passo mal e
eu fico nervoso ea gente sabe que é
autista quando fica nervoso é semelhante
a uma bola de neve vai vai e vai vai ea
gente não consegue desenrolar a bola só
cresce
então a gente não quer fazer isso
a irritar a gente quer acomodar e
trabalhar da melhor forma que a gente
pode pra alcançar o máximo do potencial
dessas pessoas
a terapia de integração sensorial essa é
a proposta
a proposta é atuando no amadurecimento e
na modificação dos circuitos cerebrais
quando eu li a primeira vez mesnik eu me
apaixonei por que ele é o pai da nossa
cidade
o cérebro e plástico a plasticidade ela
acontece do berço ao túmulo
não tem isso de janela meu filho já
passou dessa janela de falar em uma
menção a seu filho já passou dessa parte
de escreverem mais escrever já tem dez
anos e já tem 12 já tem 13
e esses altis que todos os dias graças a
deus surgem na internet com vídeos e
histórias maravilhosas começou a digitar
com 25 anos não tinha estado tanto a
falar com o pai dele
olha ai eu detesto aquela calça jeans
que minha mãe faz usar porque ela
mecânica
ela me incomoda o 25 anos depois a carta
foi digitada a primeira palavra dela com
13 anos porque ela estava passando mal
então sempre tem uma coisa que vai
impulsionar né então a gente não pode
desistir mesmo dessas pessoas
as acomodações sensoriais em casa e na
escola elas ajudam muito e por isso eu
falei aqui a respeito é de traçar um
perfil sensorial dessa pessoa eo
enriquecimento ambiental já que eu
queria dizer pra vocês é uma coisa que
você pode fazer na sua casa
eu faço isso todos os dias meu filho
acorda com música clássica 30 minutos de
de mozart vivaldi é uma coisa mais
tranqüila depois eu vou colocando uma
música mais agitada é eu colocar ondas
no quadro eu faço
nas extremidades nos pés nas mãos eu já
vou conversando com ela sobre o dia pode
acreditar que isso é muito mais útil do
que você pegar seu filho 7 horas da
manhã sem tomar café da manhã colocando
qualquer roupa e jogando ele dentro do
carro para dirigir duas horas com uma
terapia nos confins da terra é muito
melhor você coloca uma música clássica
conversar com ele leu um livro fazer uma
massagem dá um banho quente com
salamargo eu gosto muito dessas coisas
naturais e eu sempre fui pra esse lado
eu escolhi dois temas para falar
rapidamente seletividade alimentar é um
dilema na nossa vida e faz parte da
função do processamento sensorial que
pode estar influenciando tudo cor do
alimento textura do alimento temperatura
do alimento
a apresentação do prato então enquanto
essa criança tem essa seletividade e
essa junção muitas em toada a gente tem
que ser criativo mesmo a gente tem que
inventar uma vez eu vi uma notícia
falando que ela não come nada por meio
porque ela só seja com sangue
ela disse eu sei que não é tanque o
tomate automático sangue ou sangue mas
eu fiquei um tal não porque eu me
machuquei saiu muito sangue e hoje
sempre que tem um alimento vermelho não
consigo comer a minha filha da semana
conseguiu toda uma bolinha da homeopatia
porque eu falei formiga na hora de dar o
meu pai tia dela porque ela estava
comendo assim colocar as bolas na mãe
com a língua eu falei nossa você está
parecendo um tamanduá comendo formigas e
ela tem muita agonia de famílias então
na mesma hora ela é uma mãe não mamãe
dilma tudo pra cima
então assim eu falei gente não deveria
ter falado formiga neste momento nem tão
a gente não sabe muitas crianças
alan então que se passa na cabeça das
pessoas dessas crianças desses
adolescentes
a outra coisa de lenda das roupas e aí
eu vou dar umas dicas rápidas como está
o disposto na etiqueta das roupas e se a
gente tem relatado de vários artistas é
uma tortura é péssima e moroso não deixa
satisfeito porque é como se fosse uma
gilete que está avançando no meu pescoço
observe as obras prediletas da criança
que às vezes essa roupinha que ele gosta
de usar a isso gosta dessas duas
camisetas
fico que a malha dessa camiseta talvez
se você comprar outra com a mesma malha
você vai conseguir fazer com que ele
fique detido né
ontem a gente conversar sobre isso fosse
a minha mãe falou meu filho não fica não
tem jeito então eu vou e coloca uma
roupa que ele não consegue tirar você
resolver um problema na verdade sem
atuar na casa né item que também atua na
causa não é só isso que são paliativos a
gente tudo isso eu fiz com a minha filha
eu não preciso mais fazer
hoje ela fica de roupas e houve também
no certo
não preciso colocar o meia no avesso que
as costuras são pra dentro
e aí está apertado esquenta pelica
incomoda mexe nem tenta nem tento porque
se você vai comandar imagina no seu
filho no seu aluno enfim a estimulação
do pé importante a questão da marcha é
importante você considerar como essa
criança anda pra escolher o calçado
correto e caindo do pé porque tudo isso
incomoda e tudo isso vira pedra de
tropeço para o comportamento em público
tá na escola
o segredo nem seu equilíbrio num
ambiente cada autista tem um perfil
sensorial
se você conhece o seu fim
você conhece eu não se você conhece o
seu paciente no consultório
você vai procurar adaptar eu acho lindo
quando uma pessoa fala assim quando
gabriel entra na sala eu desligo um
ventilador porque eu seja isso incomoda
e não ele não suporta aquele barulho dos
ventiladores eu fecho a janela eu faço
isso é eu pus na escola os professores
um filtro nas pernas nas cadeiras para
não arrastar por causa da nato área
porque ana clara não gosto toda vez que
a gente arrasta cadeira ela tampou vida
ela começa a tremer
isso é realmente a gente tem que
respeitar
então pesquise enriquecimento ambiental
com música aromas temperaturas
diferentes tapete sensorial que é uma
coisa que pode ser feita tanto em casa
como na escola o parquinho um ambiente
rico quando você leva seu filho para
brincar no parquinho e perdura na barra
ele está fazendo propriocepção quando
ele balança ele está trabalhando o
sistema vestibular penaria pé no chão
pela grama muito estímulo muita natureza
pensa em tratamento do lixo isso é uma
coisa que necessariamente não está
dentro da do tema mas o da disfunção no
processamento sensorial é parte dessa
desse conjunto então nunca pensa isolado
que vai resolver é a fome que vai
resolver é é a psicóloga que vai
resolver é um funasa e cocada não pensa
de uma forma holística e individualizada
principalmente individualizada pesquisa
em velocidade cerebral que é maravilhoso
esse tema e aí eu tenho algumas fotos de
objetos enfim é um tapete o circuito
sensorial que o garoto está a caminho
ali as tintas as caixas sempre tem uma
caixa na minha casa que a minha filha
ama entrar dentro de espaços apertados
ela gosta de ficar dentro do espaço que
só cabe o corpinho dela fica só com a
cabeça de fora e eu sei que espera traz
conforto então eu sempre tenho essa
caixinha disponível em casa pra ela uma
caixa de plástico uma caixa de papelão
que acaba depois tendo que ser trocada
mas vale a pena
aí a minha filha ela é louca por
computador então eu tenho que realmente
tirar do caso esconder o computador hoje
ela já sabe pedir ela não falava até os
5 anos
hoje graças a deus ela já fala mas ela
fala da mãe que deus te quando a mãe o
mouse por favor
e eu fico com o coração partido porque
eu esperei cinco anos para falar e agora
não posso dar o que ela quer eu tenho
que ficar filha tudo bem eu te dou um
computador mas depois da escola agora
não é horário né
a gente vai negociando com o coração
partido mas muito feliz pelos resultados
a minha família incompleta e tem três
filhas à escola gosta muito de barco de
avião e de helicóptero de iate de todas
as pessoas que são ricas como é que
batista gosta
gente a nossa vida é um desafio
constante mas está sempre em busca de
alternativas e caminhos e soluções
eu sempre coloco três coisas na minha
vida independente de metodologia que eu
estou seguindo de tratamento que eu
consigo dar pra minha filha porque
também tem essa questão é se a gente
pudesse a gente ganha na mega sena toda
semana para dar tudo e mais um pouco
para as crianças mas quando eu penso em
um caminho alternativo em resposta eu
penso a fé é um caminho senão o caminho
a esperança é uma alternativa muito boa
o amor é o caminho ea resposta ao mesmo
tempo
então o que a gente consiga fazer tudo
isso vencer todos esses desafios com
muito amor principalmente muito obrigado